hey youtubers is Charlie hopefully you
guys have all had a chance to see the
first episode of Doctor Who since this
is our first time seeing Peter Capaldi
in a proper episode most of this video
is gonna focus on him but I'll be doing
my top 10 moments as well as some Easter
eggs that I saw at like some really
notable ones and then I'll do my review
there's also been a lot of talk about
what's happening to Clara and TV Guide
even spoiled a few big things so once I
get through the important stuff I'll
address all that but if you're finding
me for the first time I do weekly Doctor
Who videos I'm even doing a weekly
giveaway while this series is running so
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video but on to the important stuff top
ten moments so careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet I'll
wait just a sec okay ready here we go
number 10 the new title sequence I feel
like this is gonna be one of the more
controversial changes to the show
I knew they'd changed them to suit the
tone of Capaldi's run but I did not know
that they were gonna change them this
much there's actually a pretty cool
story as to why they went with the
pocket watch theme versus the time
vortex they've been using there was a
fan who made his own clockwork titles
Steven Moffat saw them and thought I'd
just be a good update the final version
they're using on the show is a little
bit different than what the fan
originally made his name is Billy
Hanshaw but he's a professional graphics
designer who makes titles like these for
a living but I still think it's really
cool that Steven Moffat would use
something that a fan made especially
since this is gonna play in front of
each episode Moffat said he felt like
they were like the best new idea for the
title sequence that he'd seen since 1963
and depending on how you count them
there's at least 13 different versions
that they've had so far here's a quick
montage
but on to number nine the grand entrance
I always like that no matter what the
doctor's personality is he always makes
a grand stage entrance getting spit up
by the dinosaur is definitely a nice
addition to the deck of cards that
comprise all the doctor's first
introductions most of what Peter Capaldi
has been saying about his doctor pegs
him as like an uncaring cold doctor but
I think that slamming the door and
strikes his face just shows how funny
it's gonna be despite the fact that he's
going to be like the new pro robot
suicide doctor which is super dark Matt
Smith was really quick with jokes but I
feel like Capaldi is a machine gun like
he just nails dry British wit if any of
you guys from the UK want to explain the
difference between British humour and
American humor please do personally I
think it's all about the subtle turn of
phrase
just being clever and biting in a very
casual way like Capaldi insulting
everyone that walks into his field of
vision but turns out it's okay because
he has gone Scottish that was really
like my favorite quote of the episode
have I gone Scottish who know I really
get to complain just for reference in
recent history David Tennant Karen
Gillan and Steven Moffat are all
Scottish in real life too but David
Tennant did not lean on his Scottish
accent whenever he took the role of the
Tenth Doctor Capaldi made it very clear
early on though that he would be keeping
his Scottish accent just as a way to
distinguish his doctor a little bit more
and I think it's great but number eight
Clara reacts to Peter Capaldi what would
you do if the person you love changed
their face I guess you'd consider that a
joke about plastic surgery but really
you know this is Clark's first
experience with the regeneration Foster
and Jenny are like a really nice analogy
for what the ideal version of their
relationship should be just loving
someone no matter how they look this
scene as well as a whole lot of the
episodes were super meta just because
it's Cara getting used to the new doctor
and it's the fandom getting used to the
new doctor so for most of the episode
we're seeing things from Clara's
perspective when vostra put him to sleep
and Clara heard him whispering he had
this really poetic speech about how
utterly lonely he is he even said it
later to the robot leader I do not
expect it to make it to paradise which
is obviously just a metaphor for
Gallifrey he is utterly alone which is
why his companion relationship is so
important in this series Capaldi's
doctor is more afraid than ever which
might explain why he insults people so
much usually that's a red flag for
insecurity I tried to find a reference
for the speech that he made in his
you know all the world is gray and I am
utterly alone I couldn't find a really
good one
other than metaltron I'm talking about
the Dalek from series 1 the ninth doctor
had a conversation with it where the
Dalek Ponder's its loneliness like it is
utterly alone because it thinks that all
the other Daleks are dead the doctor
also called this out whenever he was
talking about the dinosaur being alone
- I think it's kind of funny that the
doctor is utterly lonely but hates the
idea of hugs it's just a really funny
contradiction in his personality I
always loved all the doctors
contradictions the hugging part seems
like a very Victorian British thing to
do not being outwardly affectionate
especially in public which actually
leads me to number seven the doctor is
not cuddly anymore this is actually
taken directly from a Neil Gaiman quote
after he saw the first episode one of
the major differences in Capaldi's
portrayal as the doctor is that he does
not yearn for affection like when he
said no flirting don't get any ideas
whenever he said that all I could think
of was River Song and like any
attractive female companion the doctor
has ever had not all the doctors before
Capaldi were flirty it's mostly
something that the show has pushed since
the 2005 series began but I guess there
was also some romantic involvement
during the Doctor Who movie but the
cuddly part comes all from Matt Smith
like that's all Matt Smith's thing I
never found it off-putting but I was
pretty new to the series whenever Matt
Smith started I didn't see a lot of the
darker doctors till later so I think
about half of you guys really loved
Smith and the other half thought the
idea of a cuddly doctor was utter
rubbish I'm really excited to see how
much darker the doctor gets this series
because there were actually some moments
in the episode where he gets really dark
like darker than I've seen him before
but on to number six klar and the doctor
get reacquainted totally love the banter
they seem more like an old married
couple now or like a couple of really
old friends making fun of each other
without taking it too seriously the
doctor makes fun of her vanity and Clara
makes fun of his grey hair both of them
are saying I really care about you but
there are all these things that I really
hate about you I got such a great
Sherlock vibe from the whole episode but
the restaurant you know pre-capture was
a good example of a conversation
Sherlock would have with Watson their
relationship is actually a pretty good
metaphor for car on the doctors
relationship now the doctor is the
brilliant but crazy one and Clara is the
sensible translator who just interprets
the doctors wishes whenever he gets too
rude or starts speaking gibberish there
are also a whole lot more obvious
references like posture saying
the game is afoot and then there's
murder the doctor has taken the case
Steven Moffat did say that he was
totally open to a wholock story if
Benedict Cumberbatch and Peter Capaldi
schedules work out if something like
that eventually does come to pass I
think it'll be done more for charity
than like an actual series but number
five the rubbish robots from the dawn of
time there were reports from a long time
ago that the clockwork droids from girl
in the fireplace we're coming back the
doctor kept referencing the episode by
saying all this sounds familiar
I've seen this before and he even held
up that logo from the Marie Antoinette
so just to be clear the ship in deep
breath was the Marie Antoinette and it
was the sister ship of the Madame de
Pompadour the Papa d'Or was the ship
from girl in the fireplace so these
droids are not the same ones from that
episode even though they're based on the
same technology it's a different group
of robots searching for paradise that
whole idea about paradise is really
interesting and I'll mention it again
later when I talk about Missy but number
four the doctor does not expect to find
Gallifrey
this was another rule number one moment
where I couldn't tell if the doctor was
lying or if he was being truthful if you
believe that math Smith is in there
which he is then he's taking the long
way around to get back to Gallifrey so
he does expect to get home and he was
just lying really I think that he was
just saying whatever it took to get that
robot to jump out of the skin balloon
ship yes
remember that balloon was made out of
skin it was also a lot of fun to see him
throat immortality into the robot's face
there's no trace of you left
Capaldi cannot remember where he got his
face from like he's talking to himself
as much as he's talking to the robot he
even looked at his face and the other
side of that mirror that he held up he
also had that line earlier in the
episode where he said I've seen this
face before but I didn't put these lines
here I've seen a lot of theories that
this is a reference to Capaldi's
character from fires of Pompeii meaning
that the doctor could have chosen the
face as a sign that he really does care
despite it being against his nature as a
Time Lord if you remember in fires of
Pompeii Tennant traveled back to save
Capaldi's character in his family which
was against his rules like he brought
him onto the TARDIS
he cared so much that he broke his own
rule so it's possible that the
explanation of Capaldi's doctor face is
that he chose it to remind himself that
he cares even though he's supposed to be
the not caring doctor but the
interesting thing is is that then he
kind of turns on a dime it almost says
like yes I do have it in me to murder
you to save these people that
care about that is just like the darkest
thing I saw in the entire episode it was
so perfect we could probably spend all
day talking about that one scene but
this is what Capaldi's doctor is all
about fierce and distant but not
uncaring despite saying otherwise but
number three on to happier things the
new TARDIS whenever they started posting
promos for the episode we actually saw
some bookshelves in the distance but
here we can see him sitting in a chair
just like the Seventh Doctor his TARDIS
was made to look more like a Victorian
parlor so when Peter Capaldi's debut was
announced as a Victorian episode I
wonder if there was going to be a
connection really the changes are
relatively minor it's more of like a
color palette shift like structurally
the TARDIS is still pretty much the same
it's gotten darker but the colours have
also gotten a lot warmer which i think
is just a callback to his personality
outwardly very dark but still bigger and
warmer on the inside I'm sure as the
episodes get on will see more references
to old TARDIS's but I really love the
round things called out those of you one
of the funniest references from the 50th
anniversary whenever Smith and Tennant
saw John Hurt's TARDIS they were also
confused by the round things Kapali just
can't seem to remember where he put them
just explain that though early on and
Doctor Who's run several of the
different TARDIS consoles had the same
type of round things in the background
but on to number two phone call from
trends lore this got spoiled pretty
early on but I still enjoyed it all the
same Matt Smith came back to do the
scene they didn't film it during the
Christmas special or at least I don't
think that they filmed it during the
Christmas special it's just a way for it
Capaldi's doctor to explain Time Lord
regeneration to Clara they're all the
same person even though the faces and
personalities change thus no hugging I
did totally love that Matt Smith made a
joke about Capaldi being way too old
doctor who does like the best job at
making fun of itself without going too
far but finally my number one moment the
new mystery woman Missy I am convinced
this is not River Song despite all the
boyfriend talk I know a lot of you have
Ronnie theories Moffat referred to her
as the gatekeeper of the nethersphere
and she appears in the two-part valley
so she is very important to the series
there was also a really nice reference I
saw in that garden that she was standing
in whether or not it's the nethersphere
the garden looks mysteriously like the
garden that Amy Pond got stuck in during
the girl who waited so if you remember
in that episode paradise was literally a
resort planet called Apple loopy shaaa
it's possible that the clockwork droid
was transported there by Missy unless
it's like some sort of other place
that also made me think there might be a
thematic link to the girl who waited in
that episode the doctor chooses to leave
Amy behind to die so does that mean the
Capaldi is going to have to make the
same choice I don't think it's
coincidence that he did it whenever they
were on the clockwork ship even though
he did come back for her it might just
be foreshadowing that he's gonna have to
leave her behind for real at some point
the season but it's just something to
think about and then this issue of Clara
getting that phone number from the
mystery woman Capaldi even said whoever
she is she's very keen on keeping us
together that woman of course was Missy
so why does Missy want Clara to remain
with the doctor so I'm gonna save a lot
of my Missy theories until after we get
to know her a little bit better
hopefully she'll show up in some of
these other episodes before the finale I
don't want to jump to Ronnie too soon
but clearly she has known multiple
versions of the doctor and there are
very few females in the universe that
are as long-lived as the Time Lords but
let me know what were your favorite
things from the episode and what do you
think of Capaldi's doctor so far so
while you're thinking about that here a
couple Easter eggs that I saw the person
early in the episode who gets his eyes
stolen is served on toast from Game of
Thrones which is funny given how each of
those characters ended up then there's
the sonic devices the ones that Strax
Foster and Jenny used in the episode
were actually designed by fans during a
Blue Peter contest
my favorite Easter Egg was probably the
scarf whenever Capaldi's going on about
the clothes and says I need a long scarf
no wait that looks stupid I can only
imagine that Tom maker laughed his ass
off when he saw that it also sounds like
the doctor gave his pocket watch to the
man to get those clothes which i think
is gonna come back to bite him at a
certain point because the pocket watch
is very important add to that the
opening sequence the TARDIS is
travelling through all that clockwork
it's meant to show that they're
traveling through time but in actuality
they're travelling through the doctors
pocket watch but overall I gave the
episode a solid a for being a lot of fun
and being so different from previous
doctors despite reusing a lot of old
Moffat stuff Peter Capaldi said it best
in the episode I've seen this before and
let me know if you agree but I feel like
the Paternoster gang being so big in
this episode foreshadows potential
spin-off even though I don't expect that
to happen it feel like the episode asked
more of those characters than it has in
any previous time that I've seen them
but they're trying to show that they can
carry a series by themselves without the
doctor but so far I am totally enjoying
this new grumpy Scottish doctor and
based on what Steven Moffat has said
about all the episodes this series I
think it's going to be so much fun
like it's gonna be a big departure from
Matt Smith but I still think it's gonna
be a really good thing so I did a video
that actually kind of sums up all the
things he said and I'll had a link to it
at the end of this video in related news
my Q&A will post this Sunday so
hopefully everyone has a chance to watch
the episode or re-watch it by that time
and come up with some questions
I'll also announce the winner of the
giveaway whenever I post that remember
all you have to do to enter the giveaway
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video nice and simple and it's
open to international people too right
now you can click here to get that Q&A
I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post it and you can click here to get my
master guide for series 8 like with all
the synopsis for all the episodes and
everything that Steven Moffat said so
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow everybody let's high
five and then go read watch the episode
a couple times
you